today the council adapted without debate
regulation on energy efficiency labeling
which allows customers to be more aware
of the energy efficiency and energy
consumption of household appliances thus
helping them to reduce their energy
costs and contributing to the moderation
of energy demand the council also
reached a general approach Cannella on a
proposal for a revised directive on
energy performance of buildings its aim
is to be to promote energy efficiency in
buildings and to support cost-effective
building renovation with a view to
long-term goal of decarbonizing the
highly inefficient existing European
building stock we are very proud of
securing these council positions we send
a signal to the public that the council
is taking its energy and climate calls
commitment seriously and is ready to
engage in negotiations with the European
Parliament as soon as possible the
council was informed by the Commission
on recent developments in the field of
external energy relations including on
the recent Commission requests for a
negotiation mandate on an agreement
between EU and the Russian Federation on
the north stream to pipeline the
Commission explained that the aim of the
agreement is avoid legal uncertainty and
then sure that the onshore part of the
pipeline complies with all use relevant
legislation in this field such as the
internal in general market security of
gas supply competition and the
environment arose the 30 percent energy
efficiency target agreed today will
increase Europe's GDP of 70 billion
euros will create about 400,000 new jobs
especially amongst SMEs and will reduce
our - imports by 12% by 2070